I'm Ford Cochrane coming to you from the
Hansa Explorer in Chatham Bay off cocos
island Leandra Blanco one of the two
professional videographers on our team
invited me out for the afternoon to
shoot locations on Coco's the island is
renowned for its hundreds of spectacular
waterfalls and he's determined to film
some of them for the documentary he Manu
son Felix will make about this
expedition George a abhiyaan pilots our
zodiac raft west alone the islands north
coast past rocky cliff where Leandra
films pounding surf past sea caves and
keyholes until a long ribbon of water
comes into view we put ashore on the
cobble strewn beach then wait upstream
until the waterfall appears through the
dense forest Leandra sets up his tripod
and shoots the falls as a red crab isaam
with concern and backs away we get close
enough to see the entire cascade and
feel its spray when Alan bolaños queiroz
signals that he's found a way to climb
up beside the waterfall for a close-up
view with fall well documented we head
back to the beach where we find
intriguing designs in the stones and
wave worn driftwood as we await the
zodiacs return so far so good
you